this capsule we see a last type
of learning algorithms by
active reinforcement either the search for
plans then all the methods we have
seen until now will deliver
their plans or policies that
want to run in the environment
which is an estimate of the
optimal policy they always go the
drift and from a function of
values ​​or an action function worth
so always at some point then of
l it's equal to something like
max argue of a function that will
depend on either v2 s or q2 is
this for example and so in fact all
these methods the good all use this
kind of how to choose what is the
decision to make and are really going
just deferred to comment on what they
will estimate final either the function of
the time when the value action function
no other idea it would be to optimize
directly in fact the full so of
keep in mind a current plan then
to make changes for
get a new bonus plan followed
of a new plan worse premiums premium a
so actually locates having dug up on
the possible values ​​of a plan in
making some modifications here this
we will be looking for plans
so be an initial state s 0 which
we are interested in actually finding the
political py that maximizes the sum of
rewards future hope when I
start the simulation in 0 for example
if I want to optimize a strategy in
the frame of a game rock Tunisian ma
strategy in order to have the best
are future rewards expected at
from the beginning of the part ok so
it's true what interests me
optimize now so what I
could actually do it's just
directly optimized this policy
pilat by making changes then
it's about improving what's the value
associated this policy here again a
strong footprint a learning not
strengthening so we do not know our
transition model
so we can not calculate directly
view of the mind but by solving the
system of equations for different
besides since then optimizing the
policy
a bit like we do it in iteration by
politics so
but for each test we go
have a stochastic estimate of
calais a possible value of
rewards the sum of rewards
if I'm a politician who gave and
that I'm doing a situation I'm doing a
try a search by policy
what we are going to do is directly
optimized from against against
results of stochastic simulations
politics then so that's a little
as an alternative a variant
learning not reinforcement of
the political iteration we saw
in the decision process mark
well in the case where we know the model
of transition
so in this case also it is the variant
finally the nation by politics but
in case
in fact we do not know in the end
our transition model and it's this
we are going to call the search for plans
or political or English not so sure
for example if we return an example of
of environment of a grid 3 by
four ben if we do a simulation
for a policy that gives and we will
observe a reinforcement sequence
can that good blowjob is that vida
es 0 it's going to be its value is going to be
relatively close to 0.72 so the
sum of all these reinforcements to see there
some variation
but since that's one of the results
possible v20 is going to be anyway
relatively close to this value
then a search approach of
politics we will see here that the sum
we will see who is very simple if you
make an approach by el campo
we will actually use research
local
we will convert the problem of doing
learning by inevitably as a
local search problem is this
that we could do is for a
number of iterations we're going
take our current policy picon
will initialize in a certain way so
here would possibly have the first
handle initialize civilized then
maybe randomly is there at
each iteration will take our
current policy
we will do a test so a simulation
in the environment and then it goes us
give an estimate of the value for
this policy there in zero because I
do and I'm just going to cumulate to
from the beginning
all reinforcements until the end and
then fir trees for each policy
neighboring of a successor policy of
my current policy which so my little
neighbor I will call him who premium but
I'm going to do a simulation with
each of these new policies there
these policies change that will give me
a value of the sum of the rewards
from the beginning to the end
I will compare that with my values
current of the 2 0 so my new
value life I compare it with it
makes 2 0 here it's better if it's a
politics gives me a better money
rewards until the end but I
just want to changed my policy for
my new policy that takes precedence over
neighboring policy then the value of 1st
s 0 this policy this is going to be the
value life I do that for everything but
neighboring policies then I start again
like that so take my new
current policy generating these
neighboring politics successor policy
to her and to look if I can not
improved this policy there he continued
like that for a number
of iterations then we need a
way to generate successors to a
politics that gave and ben
the alternative a possibility that would be
if I'm two years old, vary the action
for a
only state and do it for all
possible states
so if i had politics in pid es 0
chf the action to the ppp of the only
threesome but i could say that
I will take the same action as a
party animal correction to May 3 instead I
will do in 0 the action to 2 or l
reverse i will keep 1-0 action 1
but in the state is this a I'm rather
take the action together and so that
would be put two neighboring policies that
I would have to test in my algorithms
and see also there is not one of the two
which improves in relation to my policy
running this being said it's a
approach that brand me worked well
I if the state space and not too much
serious
then if tired of actions and small
when if I had two actions
possible for each of the states if
I had three possible actions here
I should consider the case where at the
place of l2 it would be the third
same action here so we can see
that many successor policies for
easily explode if I have a lot
of steps that a lot of actions
possible
so that's one of the problems and we
could always have imagined doing a
so random sampling choose
randomly some of the stuffs
parise some reactions randomly
so I will not discuss how to do
optimization this process there and I
want to do it earlier to literature
to see ways to attack this
problem there but the problem that is
especially important is the one
linked to the fact that we made a lot of
stochastic variations in values
we will observe because a
simulation
there is a stochastic aspect because
my environment and possibly
stochastic and not necessarily
deterministic it means that for the
same policy given in doing I'm going
maybe observe if I do two
simulations independent of values ​​well
different and that makes me go
maybe did change my policy
just because by chance my
new policy successor and more
was better than the other
so for example if I have some
strategy I'm in poker which a
politics that I am to play at
poker but necessarily the fact that I
give us not your depend on maps
that I'm going to get it and that's not something
thing that I control and it can
than a player a better strategy
lost this tilting opponent players
for a hand given one of the best qu
so we would like that before
a way to control this factor there he
is a way of doing that way not bad
interesting so the idea is we want
control the variations of a
simulation to another and if we have access to
a generator so it's actually done
simulations on computer and that
it's the environment in which our
money made take actions betty
that we can do is that at the beginning of
each simulation done we will initialize
our random number generator
simulator
allamumma metals for me but my
my initial policy which if I have a
political then current
I'm doing a simulation that will give me
a value v2 0 and the cij considers a
neighborly politics that premium
the simulation I'm going to do I'm going
do it with the same state of the generator
of random numbers so in the case
of a card game actually it would like
say that leave the same cards that
are going to be digging in the same way so that
will allow to control for these
variations there that could have a
greater influence on value
of a simulation that the policy that has
been followed so this general idea the
cct laws that is followed by
great pegasus who the algorithm that is
used for simulations so
acrobatic with a cape town such a
idea that we saw at the very beginning of this
section 6 of the co I give you the link
here if you want to see said if
other simulations the 2 of this
algorithm that took them controlled
nil buddies then you will also have
references to articles that
describe a little better the comment this
that this system controls it a
sensors were unlocked so that's it
it is very fast fast flyby of
comment on what we can do
looking for plans to do
active learning and what are the
issues consider it in the way
what did the plan searches did to
comment on what we sign that we generate
neighboring new policies having
also realized that it takes
control the variations related or to the
stochastic city of our environment
for example by controlling the choice
from the normal generation to the right
between different simulations